-It is a pleasure to meet you.
I'm a big fan of yours.
I got to tell you. "The Menu."
You were so fantastic
in that movie.
-Hey. Thank you very much.
-I loved it.
If you haven't seen that movie,
check this out.
-Yeah, it's good.
-I didn't know what it was
gonna be about going into it.
I just thought, like,
it was people eating
at a fancy restaurant
or something.
-Well, it is kind of about that.
Like, the worst guests
possible at a fancy restaurant
and everything
that's wrong with them.
And I was one of
the terrible guests.
-But, gosh, you made me laugh.
It's very funny, by the way,
I should mention, too.
-It is funny.
-A very twisted dark comedy.
-Yeah, but, gosh, you made me
laugh when you started --
It reminded me
a little bit of me
because I watched it
with my wife,
and I loved those shows
like "Chef's Table,"
all that stuff,
and they're like,
"This, you know,
scallop was found."
And I'm like,
"Oh, it's just beautiful."
And your char--
And my wife's like,
"It's a scallop,"
or, you know, whatever.
But I always freak out.
I got, "Oh, my God."
You know,
I love those shows.
And your character
at one point starts crying
when he's --
-He does.
He gets -- He gets misty-eyed.
He gets emotional about it.
-He gets misty-eyed, emotional.
It's so funny.
-Yeah.
-And then it gets --
It gets nuts. But, man,
you were fantastic in that.
-Thank you very much.
That's very kind of you.
-I have a picture of one scene
from the movie.
-This -- So, this --
This is one of my -- This --
-So it is funny. I'm telling
you, it is a comedy, but...
-This is one
of my proudest moments
because this image
has kind of become a meme,
and I never expected
to become a meme for this.
-Congratulations.
-But, also,
it's kind of ridiculous
because this is a moment
when I've been forced to cook
in the film
and my character,
who thinks he knows
everything about cooking,
has been forced to cook.
And he's terrible at it.
Truly terrible.
So this has become a meme for
people who are bad at things.
[ Laughter ]
Which I never --
-No, no. It doesn't mean you.
No, no. It's the character.
-I'm the face of, like, someone
who's bad at something.
-No! Not at all. Not at all.
-And I was like,
"Damn. How did this happen?"
But also I'm very proud of it.
-He's whispering something
in your ear.
Do we -- We never hear what
he's whispering in your ear.
Is that --
-No, no, no, it wasn't --
It wasn't scripted,
what he whispers in my ear.
And Ralph is fantastic.
-Ralph Fiennes.
He's one of the greatest.
He was phenomenal in this,
as well.
-Yeah.
And he -- and he would --
he would deliver
different things...
-To get different emotions?
-...different things in my ear.
-I wonder what whispers
to get this scared --
Look at that.
You're a great actor, bud.
-You don't want to know
what he was saying.
-I don't want to know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I want to know about this,
by the way.
I follow you on the socials
on Twitter.
And I looked at your --
your Twitter bio, okay?
-By the way,
it's like 15 years old.
-Yeah.
-I should probably update that.
-Yeah, exactly.
But this one here says
"Marble egg enthusiast,"
which --
-Yeah.
-Now, is that assuming,
like, marbles?
Is that what that is?
-You know, just like
marble, the stone.
-Oh.
-But just eggs.
[ Laughter ]
They're not interesting.
I think when I was a kid
I thought they would, like,
maybe hatch dragons
or something.
So I liked them,
and I had a little collection.
Aww. Thank you. Yeah.
-So you really mean
marble eggs?
-Just -- They don't do anything,
and I'd just get them out
as a kid and hold them,
and then I'd put them back away
and keep them safe,
and it's like -- I don't know.
-Maybe they were dragon eggs.
We don't know.
I mean, they could be
hatching right now.
-I'm like Gollum
with my, like, little --
-Yes. Exactly.
"Game of Thrones."
Whoa. Wow. I didn't know
you meant marble eggs.
-I shouldn't have put that
in my bio now I think about it.
-No, I like that a lot.
Next time, we should have
marble eggs on and look at them.
-Please. Yeah.
-But then the first thing
really made me laugh.
"Berkshire County Athletics
2005 discus bronze medalist."
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So...
-You're in the presence
of greatness.
[ Laughter ]
-There he is.
Winning the --
-Good stitch-back.
That was nice. Well played.
-How did you win
the bronze medal there?
-I know. It's surprising
I didn't get the gold.
The weird thing was,
it was only the second time
I think I'd ever really,
ever thrown a discus, as well.
I did it once in P.E.,
and then they were like,
"Oh, you threw it kind of okay.
Do you want to do ---
Do you want to do County?"
And I was like, "Yeah, alright."
And I never even learned
how to do, like,
the spinning proper throw.
-You didn't even spin it.
-I just stood there
and went, "Ugh!"
And that was it.
But then the people
that were there
that were actually
great discus throwers
who obviously --
that was, like, their skill --
they kept --
You know, if you walk out
the front of the circle, you
foul out, and it doesn't count.
-Disqualified.
-They kept on
getting disqualified.
So it was kind of by default.
I ended up
getting the bronze medal.
-Yeah, that's what I'm talk--
That's a winner!
-I've still got the medal,
and I have it with pride.
-See? Never give up.
Never give up.
That's the --
That's the point there.
I want to talk about
your new movie, "Renfield."
This, again, is a comedy.
-Yes.
-Dark comedy.
-Yeah, it's a -- it's a comedy
about kind of
this toxic relationship,
this narcissistic boss, Dracula.
Kind of the worst boss
you could imagine.
-Yeah.
-Played by Nicolas Cage.
-Nicolas Cage as Dracula!
Come on, bud!
-Yeah. It's amazing.
-He's the best!
-I don't think my career
will ever get better than, like,
being in a scene...
-Look at this.
-...with the iconic Nicolas Cage
playing Dracula.
It's just like...
[ Cheers and applause ]
And he's having so much fun
and he's brilliant in the movie.
So it was amazing to shoot it.
And it's an action comedy
about my character
kind of finding
this support group
and this network to try
and try and believe in himself
and escape this boss
who has him,
you know, killing people
to feed his bloodlust.
-Yeah. Yeah, we could
all relate to that.
Yes, of course.
-Your typical story.
-Your character gets
special powers.
Not by eating people's blood,
though.
-No.
-You eat insects, bugs?
-Yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's kind of a classic thing
from the the Bram Stoker novel,
Renfield consumes life.
And for our story,
it's been updated.
It's 100 years on and Renfield
kind of gets
superhuman abilities,
I guess, from eating bugs
So there was a fair amount
of bug eating.
-Yeah. It's a silly question
for me to ask
because I shouldn't
have said this earlier.
I said, "Did you eat
real bugs on set?"
-Yes. Yes.
-And you said you did.
-I did, yeah. Yeah.
No, so it depends.
The props department
were incredible.
And they did build, like,
for cockroaches,
we had, like, caramel ones
that looked very authentic.
So they were yummy.
For the worms,
it was like gummy worms in,
like, crushed up
Oreos to look like earth.
So again, very yummy.
The one bad one was potato bugs.
Potato bugs were -- They were
real and they were disgusting.
That was not a nice flavor.
But I have brought some along,
some of the yummier ones
for you to try if you fancy.
These are crickets. Crickets.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Take them out. Take them out.
So these are like --
These are dried
and they're flavored.
They're, um...
Voilà.
We've got salt and vinegar
and cheese and bacon,
I think, are the flavors.
-I really don't want
to do this, but I will.
-Now, I thought my bug-eating
days were over, but now,
like, doing the press tour...
-You've eaten more bugs
than you have in the movie.
-Everyone's like,
"Eat another bug."
-[ Laughs ] "Eat another bug."
-So here I am and I'll do it.
You know what?
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're not the best I've
ever had, I'm going to say.
-Alright. But what is that?
Was that the salt and vinegar?
Or is that -- Doesn't matter.
-I think that was
the cheese and bacon.
-Does it matter at this point?
You're eating crickets.
-There's a wing on your desk.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Sorry.
-This is so --
-You can do it.
-I know, but I'm not
in this movie.
-Just chuck the whole thing.
-Yeah, right. Oh, my God.
Alright.
-They're quite bitty.
They got stuck in there.
-The leg just came off.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's good.
How do you feel?
-No, no, no. It's interesting.
It's not that bad,
but I wouldn't choose --
-It's the thought of it that's
worse than the actual thing.
-It tastes like a veggie stick.
-Yeah, well, you know,
me and Nic Cage
were saying yesterday
when we were doing press, we
were like, "Oh, you know what?"
Like, I mean, if we got over
our fear of eating insects,
really, it's like great protein,
low fat.
It would solve world hunger
in many ways.
So it's like we were thinking
that maybe we'd start up
a brand of like
the Two Nicks Insect Emporium
and start, like,
selling dried insects.
So, you heard it here first.
-Let's get working on that.
Yeah. Of course.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Nicholas Hoult
in "Renfield."
Take a look at this.
-I work for Dracula.
-What?
-Dracula.
-Count Dracula.
-No. No. President Dracula.
Yes. Yes. Sorry. Count Dracula.
I'm -- I'm his familiar. I --
You know, I tend to his needs,
including care, feeding,
you know, anything,
especially during
the daylight hours.
-Like, you get
Dracula people to eat?
-I do other stuff too.
-Like what? Wash his cape?
-No. That's dry clean only.
-There you go.
Nicholas Hoult.
"Renfield" is in theaters
April 14th.
We have magic from Penn and
Teller after the break.
Stick around, everybody.